i don't know if this is a popular
opinion or not but i love oh
love when liars get caught and i'm
talking about a certain type of lie
and liar i'm not talking about like a
white lie here or there
i'm not talking about a lie to you know
make someone feel better
i'm talking about self-serving lies that
are supposed to make you look good
and this takes many forms photoshop on
instagram and then claiming you didn't
photoshop a picture
you're lying you're lying to make
yourself look good
and in the process you're bringing down
the self-esteem of everybody else
because they think oh that's not
photoshop
when somebody takes steroids and says
they're all natural that's not only
self-serving it also hurts everybody
else
i love when that stuff gets called out
and caught
so forgive me but i wanted to spend
today talking about dan bilzerian
the king of instagram uh 34 million
followers
such a popular guy well
yeah that uh his little empire's been
falling apart lately
and i just want to cover it for you guys
now if you don't know dan bilzerian he's
like this
hugh hefner of instagram but probably
the biggest thing he's known for
and is consistently lying about is that
he says he made all his money from poker
when in fact he's just a trust fund baby
from a dad who was accused of fraud
and thrown in jail for being a corporate
raider in the 80s the dad was fined by
the sec millions of dollars
he hid all the money in trust funds and
shell companies and had been shuffling
around the money ever since
uh and that's how dan balzerian got his
money now dan bulsarian denies all this
says no
it's because i'm such a good poker
player did you make your money then
playing poker you made it all playing
poker yeah wow that is insane
even though professional poker players
have come around and said actually he's
not that good at all
but somehow through hooker crook dan
balzerian has basically parlayed all
this media attention
into what he was pushing as a legitimate
lifestyle company
ignite they were selling cannabis they
were selling alcohol
they were just selling all sorts of
party stuff that fits with his
fraternity brand but it turns out you
can take the trust fund baby image out
of the trust fund baby
but you can't take the trust fund baby
attitude
out of the trust fund baby because
ignite
is being basically nose dived into the
ground
into uh yeah oblivion bankruptcy
whatever you want to call it
by dan bulsarian now what do i mean by
that well
back in 2016 people were saying ignite's
going to be run
like a lean and mean ship oh yes very
lean and mean they're going to be cash
flow positive
by 2020 have no fear and with that they
got all these investors involved
and they got all this funding involved
and basically dan bilzerian has been
using all of this as a personal piggy
bank so the annual filing just came out
and uh it turns out they made 10 million
dollars in sales which isn't bad until
you realize that his company
lost 50 million dollars
uh in operational costs marketing all
that stuff
look honestly you'd think that a guy
like dan belizarian wouldn't spend
anything on marketing right he's got
this huge instagram following just push
it through your instagram but no
they spent 22 million dollars on
marketing
while only making 10 million dollars in
sales why
because dan bilzerian has no idea how
money works i think when dan balzerian
was born
his dad just handed them a bunch of
money uh and so he doesn't understand
that you can't spend more
than you make i don't know if you just
missed the company memo or what
but what he's spending on too is just
embarrassing he's spinning on things
like a sixty thousand dollar star wars
gun set
which he wrote off as a business expense
a thirty one thousand dollar pool
renovation
fifty thousand dollars for a bed frame
fifteen thousand dollars for ping pong
table
and eighty eight thousand dollars on a
vault yes guys
yes this is necessary for company
operating expenditures
he's just using the whole company as
more of a trust fund credit card you
know
and honestly i don't feel bad for these
investors one bit
you knew what you signed up for with dan
bilzerian you knew he was a trust fund
baby how did you expect
he was going to spend your money you
thought he was going to turn into some
genius ceo
you know 500 iq ceo being like guys we
must cut
operating costs and run it all
run with a lean model no he's he's gonna
do what damn bulzarian does
and what i love is that just a few days
ago
a video came out where kevin o'leary you
know the shark tank guy
uh toured the his little mcmansion which
now
dan balzerian's kicked out of in this
piece it says that he owns the house and
paid 65 million dollars for it
he reportedly paid a mind-boggling 65
million dollars for this mega mansion
but actually it turns out he was renting
it all along
yes yes i love this stuff i love it
when liars get caught you say you own
the house
but you don't you don't own the house
instead it was found out that he's
paying 200
000 a month to rent the house you know i
hope people are opening their eyes this
guy is not some brilliant
genius he's not some guy who
bootstrapped his way from nothing he's
just a trust fund baby that's it
and honestly the other thing that shows
is that uh yeah all these instagram
followers mean nothing
if people don't like you you guys
remember that instagram girl
who had like 2 million followers but she
couldn't sell like 36 t-shirts
well this is the basically the
equivalent of that because dan balzerian
is getting
400 million weekly impressions from
instagram but he can only sell 10
million dollars of product
that's 20 billion views
and you can only sell 10 million in
product that's embarrassing
you can make more money from youtube ads
than dan balzerian's making
from an actual company put let me repeat
that
dan balzerian if he just had a youtube
channel getting the same number of views
he'd be making more from adsense than
he's right now making
from like this big company that he's
built and spending 22 million dollars on
so at the end of the day guys yeah these
influencers that
they're getting big numbers whatever it
doesn't make them
marketable it doesn't mean that people
are going to buy their products at the
end of the day
and it definitely doesn't mean you
should invest in them so that's it i
hope you enjoyed
you know just experiencing this little
guilty pleasure with me
and i'll see you guys next time and
don't forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you